بالعوده الى قرار الاداره الامريكيه تعيين
ممثل خاص لشؤون الفلسطينيه حيث نسلط الضوء
على تاريخ العلاقات الفلسطينيه الامريكيه
لا تعترفوا واشنطن بدوله فلسطين وليس
للولايات المتحده اي مكتب تمثيليا
دبلوماسي او قنصلي داخل اراضي السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه المعلنه بمقتضى اتساق
اوسلو على
1993 ورغم ان العلاقات بين الحكومه
الامريكيه وبنظمه التحرير كممثله للشعب
الفلسطيني قائمه منذ السبعينيات فان
الولايات المتحده لم تسمح بفتح مكتب
المنظمه في واشنطن الا عن عام
1994 عندما الغي الرئيس بالكلانطن قانون
ينصه على عدم احقيه الفلسطينيين بفتح
مكاتب لهم على الاراضي الامريكيه في اواخر
عام 2002 قرر رئيس الاسبق جورج بوش الابنه
مكتب منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه في
الولايات المتحده بحجه عدم منظمه التحرير
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لبعض تعهداتهما لكن في
يوليو تموز من العام 2010 قررت اداره
الرئيس باراك اوباما رفع مستوى تمثيل
المنظمه ليصبح المفوضيه العامه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه في واشنطن وهو مستوى
بروتوكوليون اعلى من وضعها السابق وسرعان
ما تبخرت تلك الخطوه باستصدار اداره ترامب
قرارا من الكونغرس في نوفمبر 2017 يشترط
استمرار مكتب منظمه التحرير بامتناع
الفلسطينيين عن ملاحقه اسرائيل امام
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه على جرائمها
وبنضمام فلسطين رسميا الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه اغلقت اداره الرئيس
ترامب مكتبه المنظمه في واشنطن عام 2000
2018 فضلا عن نقل السفاره الامريكيه الى
القدس واغلاق القنصليه الامريكيه العامه
في القدس الشرقيه التي تاسست على الفا 18
خلال حملته الانتخابيه تعهد الرئيس
الامريكي جو فايدن ميرارا وتكرارا باعاده
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه للفلسطينيين
بالقدس الشرقيه مما شكل
مبررالسلطه الفلسطينيه لاعاده العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده بعد قطعها اسرع اعتراف
اداره ترامب القدس عاصمه اسرائيل ونقل
السفاره الامريكيه اليها وفي سبتمبر من
العام الماضي اكد مشاريعون امريكيون هم
كريس ميرفي وريتشرد
وجون او سوف ضروره اعاده فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه لخدمه
الفلسطينيين بشكل افضل وذلك خلال لقائهم
مسؤولين اسرائيل في القدس تحديدا بعد نحو
شهر من ذلك جدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
لكن تعهد اداره الرئيس بايدا بالمضيق قدما
في خطتها لاعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه
في القدس ضمن سماها جهود تعليق العلاقه مع
الفلسطينيين واواخر ايار مايو الماضي وقبل
زياره بيت الشرق الاوسط قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه نترايس الى واشنطن لا
تزال ملتزمه باعاده فتح قنصليه الامريكيه
في القدس وهي تواصل مناقشه المساله مع
الاسرائيليين مع الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين